today on the matt well show under
biden's leadership the united states
military will now condemn
and try to intimidate journalists who
criticize its policies
is that a positive development i don't
think so but we'll talk about it also
five headlines including controversy
over a joke about feminists at the
grammys
not as much controversy though about an
onstage strip show however
and the vatican makes headlines by
affirming church teaching that has been
in place for 2 000 years breaking news
finally in our daily cancellation we'll
deal with the woke school in new york
that has now banned the words mom and
dad on grounds that they aren't
inclusive enough
all of that and much more today on the
matt wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
we discussed on friday the reaction to
tucker carlson's controversial comments
about women in the military
and of course when i say controversial i
mean that the point he made was
indisputably correct and totally in line
with science and basic common sense as
we know
you know those kinds of comments uh the
con that would be the common sense
comments are the most controversial
these days
so it's a review briefly carlson reacted
to
president biden's announced efforts to
recruit more women
including pregnant women into the
military carlson pointed out that
other countries like china are trying to
masculinize
their militaries while we are apparently
trying to feminize ours
that's not a good thing he says and i
would agree
you know we we know it's not good based
again on common sense
men are faster stronger more aggressive
more lethal so it stands to reason that
the more men you have in your military
as a percentage the stronger faster more
aggressive
and more lethal you're lethal your
military will be the less
you have as a percentage um the weaker
slower and
less lethal you will be now you don't
have to have a phd in mathematics to
work out this equation
and if common sense judgments aren't
your thing then you can look at the
empirical data as mentioned on friday
the marine corps
did a study on this very subject a few
years ago and found that all male
units were better by every relevant
measure than male
than um than mixed gender units we also
know that the navy seals opened up their
ranks to women a while ago
but no woman has succeeded in actually
becoming a navy seal not because they're
barred from entry anymore i mean
they can attempt to become a navy seal
they haven't succeeded in doing that
even when given the opportunity why well
because the seals are an elite force
and all of the apparently elite members
of the military
are men now further on the empirical
front
the daily wire had this report just
yesterday
it says the united states army is
reportedly considering doing away
with its new gender-neutral physical
test after test results showed that the
majority of women
failed while approximately 90 of men
passed
officials are reportedly considering
having different evaluation categories
for men and women
due to the physiological differences
between the two hmm
physiological differences might be some
significance to that i mean maybe
there's
physiological differences to make women
less effective in combat i don't know
continuance has research showed that the
army combat fitness test which is the
same for male and female soldiers was
leading to lower results for women
with a knock-on effect for promotions
the telegraph reported
an early pentagon study showed that
women were failing
the acft at a rate of 65 percent
65 percent while only 10 percent of men
failed
a report from last fall found that 54 of
women failed the test while only 7
percent of men failed it
the report said that congress which is
controlled by democrats
stopped the new program from being
implemented and the army is reviewing
whether it's
fair congress does not want the test as
it is currently constructed to factor
into
opportunities for advancement according
to the report
okay we have to ask ourselves
is it good or bad generally speaking
when the army is getting rid of
or lowering physical standards in order
to be inclusive
of anyone including women
would you say that our military is more
or less effective more or less
intimidating more or less equipped to
defend our nation
when it lowers its physical standards in
the name of inclusivity
and feminism here's another question
with an answer just as obvious
is it good or bad when uniformed
military leaders begin publicly
attacking journalists who criticize
government policy
what we've seen over the past several
days is i think truly unprecedented at
least in modern american history
i can't remember anything like this ever
happening
i mean the military has of course been
severely criticized by the media through
the years
as long as there's been a media it's
been crit it has criticized the military
and military policy
this is right and proper in a free
country we should have a media that
criticizes the military
um it's also right and proper that the
military has had a policy of mostly
ignoring these criticisms
we don't pay our military leaders to be
pundits
they can do that when they retire a lot
of them do fine
but it's better if they refrain while
they're still on the job and this
had been the precedent until the last
few days when branches of the military
including the marine corps
came out in an official capacity on
their official social media channels
and attacked tucker carlson by name
for critiquing their policies u.s marine
corps
master gunnery sergeant scott stalker
posted on the u.s space command's
official government twitter account
going after carlson spouting a bunch of
half-baked feminist nonsense
then an official marine corps account
for the mef
information group joined in chastise
carlson calling him a boomer
and posting a picture of a female marine
carrying a male marine
perhaps not incidentally they didn't
post a video
of this happening only the picture
probably because they didn't want us to
see that she carried him only for long
enough to take the picture and then
dropped him right away
the pentagon also responded so did army
general paul funk
head of training and doctrine command
and sergeant major of the army michael
grinston
this is just a partial list of people
currently in positions of leadership
in the military responding in official
capacities
to this commentator on fox news
now the responses from the marines are
especially ironic and troubling
ironic because it was the marines own
study which found that mixed gender
units are less effective
so the marines are now condemning a
member of the media
for agreeing with the results of their
own study which came
out in like 2016. it wasn't 50 years ago
also troubling because it's the marines
for god's sake
if they go full feminist then i mean
what hope do we have
but of course through all this the media
has cheered the military leaders
who have uh put on their uniforms and
delivered politically motivated
rhetorical attacks in their official
capacities as spokesman for the military
that is the people who panicked over the
rise of
fascism for the past four years are now
applauding military officials for
behaving exactly as military officials
would behave under a fascist
dictatorship
i mean can you imagine how the media
would have reacted
if military generals in uniform had
chastised let's say
don lemon for criticizing trump's
military policies
can you imagine that
how they would react to that because
again the issue here is it's the
military
not simply defending itself which by the
way it's not its job to do that either
it's the military's job to defend itself
and the country on the battlefield
it's not its job to defend itself um
on the battlefield of cable news it's
supposed to be above that and beyond
that
and focused on things other than that
but it's not just that it's not it's not
the military defending itself
it's these military leaders offending uh
defending rather
president biden's policies
they're coming to the defense of biden's
policies
because that is what was criticized
biden's policies
now imagine again if this had happened
under trump
if trump had his military leaders in
uniform
on tv and on the internet defending his
policies
i mean that would have been six months
of outraged headlines right there
more than six months we would have quite
literally never heard the end of it
and the media certainly would have
considered it proof of their fascism
claim
and they'd be right actually in that
case it would be at least be evidence of
fascism
now am i saying that biden's government
is fascist no i mean fascist isn't the
right word
but it is tyrannical and oppressive in
its own way
leftist governments always are and this
one as we have seen
is surely no exception
let's get now to our five headlines
you know one thing is clear that big
tech companies to put it
mildly have a lot of power uh in our
country today and a lot of control over
our lives
and as private entities they can operate
pretty much as they choose that's why
you got to protect your personal data
from big tech with the vpn that i trust
my online protection that's expressvpn
when i use expressvpn my connection gets
rerouted through their secure
encrypted servers so these companies
can't see my ip address at all that's
going to give me privacy which
which which i need and i think we all
deserve
when we're online there's no reason why
going online should have to mean that
you sacrifice all of your
privacy and it doesn't mean that because
you can get expressvpn my internet
activity becomes
anonymous and my network network
activity is encrypted
i recommend expressvpn to anyone who
uses the internet so basically
to to everyone i i think we all use the
internet so i'm recommending it to
everybody
and the best part is you don't need to
be tech savvy at all to use expressvpn
like i always tell you
if you had to be expressed if you had to
be tech savvy to use it then i wouldn't
be using it or recommending it but
i can use it which means that you can
all you have to do this is this is what
it comes down to
just download the app on your phone
computer and tap a button
and you're done you're protected it's
that easy protect your internet activity
with the vpn that i use
every day and now's the time to use it
to give yourself
a little bit of privacy and some control
where big tech tries to take it away
visit expressvpn.com
walsh to get three extra months free on
a one-year package that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s
vpn.com wall should get three extra
months for free expressvpn.com
walsh well i hope you guys are enjoying
daylight savings time so far um
well you know we're we're a couple days
into daylight savings can i just say i i
don't like the daylight savings
slander and defamation that goes on i am
i'm uh
i like daylight if i'm the only one left
in the world who does or i i will say i
like daily savings time
it is uh nobody knows why we do it no
one knows
no one can explain it it's something
that we do it's a sacred tradition
it's the sacred tradition of our
forefathers and their father's before
them
we take part in this mysterious dance of
changing the clock back and forth
nobody knows why but we do it and and
that's what makes it special
also you know the other thing it's it's
a big idea
you know daylight savings say what you
want about it
it's a big idea right an interesting
idea
we're actually manipulating or trying to
manipulate time itself
and you don't get those kinds of ideas
anymore can you imagine
if daylight savings never existed
and and the concept never existed and
then in the year 2021 someone suggested
it
like let's say some politician suggested
that we that we do this
came along and said hey you know um you
know in the summertime
it's warm out we want to spend more time
outside but it gets dark around like
6 30. well what if we pretend
that 6 30 is really 7 30. what if we all
agree to
just pretend that the clock has moved
forward in an hour
then we get an extra day of extra hour
of daylight
if someone suggested that now we would
look at them like they're insane we
wouldn't even consider it
yet because it was suggested decades ago
we all just do this we go along with it
and i'm saying that like it's a pot it's
like it's a good thing
it's again it's utterly pointless no
reason to do it but we do it anyway and
i for one appreciate that
all right speaking of things that um are
pointless and have no reason to be done
the stimulus checks
uh has started to go out this uh this
past weekend
nbc news reports stimulus checks are
starting to land on americans bank
accounts across the country this weekend
just days after president joe biden
signed the 1.9 trillion dollar
american rescue plan into law um
this is he signed the thing into law and
these and these checks started hitting
almost instantly people were getting
them in their in their check in their
bank accounts the third round of direct
payments which follows two previous sets
of payments
are the most substantial yet although
some of the people included in the last
deal
won't be eligible this time um those who
make less than 75
000 or heads of households who make less
than 112 000
are eligible for the full 1400 payment
individuals earning less than 80 000 and
heads of households making less than 120
000
are still eligible for reduced payments
couples who file taxes jointly qualify
for the full payment if they're up to
150
000 and receive partial payments if they
make up to 160 i don't know why i'm
reading this
i mean if you got the money in your bank
account you already know how much you
got um
and then fit 1400 or more for each child
including children over 18 including
children over 18.
did i know that i'm just reading that
now look i already complained about this
on
friday people don't like it when i
complain about this because yeah people
like free money which i understand
and and we all know that giving
millions of people who didn't lose their
jobs
now i know that some of the people
getting the money did lose their jobs
and need the money
i understand that but also there are
millions of people getting the money
who did not lose their jobs and are not
suffering any particular
financial hardship they're doing okay at
least they're doing as well as they were
doing a year ago before the pandemic
started
and give them all money why there's no
reason to do it there's no just there's
no
reasonable justification for this
and i think everyone knows that but you
also like free money so you prefer if we
don't
talk much about it and of course if you
get the money you want to feel guilty
about it which i've already said listen
if you get the money i'm not saying you
should feel guilty uh
they sent it to you what else are you
going to do with it
i'm not saying you send it back to the
government fine you keep it you spend it
or better yet save it so i'm not saying
that at all but
can we at least agree
or acknowledge that this is totally
insane to be doing this
spending billions of dollars sending
huge checks to people who don't even
need it
and it's worse than that in fact because
we set this arbitrary
income line well you know what they're
going to be a lot of like single people
who make under that that income level
but are doing
perfectly fine they've got you know they
don't have any dependents they're doing
well
they didn't lose any money maybe they
even got a raise
i mean with this system you could have
people who got
raises during the pandemic and are
actually making more money and doing
better than they were doing before
and they get checks meanwhile you could
have people
heads of households people that have
dependents and children who suffered
devastating financial losses during the
pandemic but get
nothing because they still technically
make over the
totally arbitrary income threshold that
was set up
so it's worse than simply giving money
to people don't need it
you're giving money to people who don't
need it instead of
giving it to people who do need it
instead of
instead of taking the time putting the
effort in to figure out
who actually lost money during the
pandemic who lost their job
who actually suffered financial
misfortune let's help them out
rather than doing that we're gonna give
it you know we're gonna send a check to
some
single guy living on his own
making 70 thousand dollars a year doing
perfectly fine
let's send them a check yeah why not
like i think of a lot of reasons why not
but
we did it anyway all right number two
the grammys happened yesterday
of course i didn't watch those at all
because i
value my time and my sanity um i am told
though by the
the media that cardi b and megan
the stallion i don't know that's how
it's pronounced
so cardi b and migandi stallion uh
performed
their their hit single of course [ __ ] and
i'm told by the media it was an x-rated
performance they were
it's basically a stripping on not
basically they actually had stripper
poles and they were stripping on stage
um and this is of course being
celebrated and what a wonderful
feminist expression of of
female you know independence and and all
of an enlightenment
and all of that so
we've got that we've got these
filthy rich people on stage performing
on a strip pull
network tv you know at a time of night
when there are still
plenty of kids that are still awake and
we're doing that that that's great
fantastic um but the muppets
we have to have a parental disclaimer on
the muppets we gotta get rid of the dr
seuss books
and we gotta have a disclaimer on on
peter pan
and in fact we have to take peter pan
disney plus has taken peter pan
and taking it off of the children's
profiles on their on their streaming
service
because we don't want to expose kids to
that and putting it on you know and
and offering that bit of insulation from
from the kids because we don't expose
kids to peter pan or the muppets
or uh if i ran a zoo by dr seuss
don't expose them to that
but sure these uh these two women on a
strip hole singing about their genitalia
fantastic i really you know talk about
this new version of puritanism and these
are the new puritans we've talked about
it plenty of times
these are the new puritans they get
offended
and are worried about the um the impact
of cartoons
pepe le pew cartoon skunk the word about
the impact
of cartoons and children's books
but not [ __ ] and i really do prefer it's
it's this inverted puritanism
and i really do prefer the old style
puritans
i didn't agree with everything they
thought and everything they did but at
least they were coherent
you could say that much for them
bill burr uh comedian he did spark
outrage now
the the the strip show on stage there's
no outrage there that's fine all we
could do because you don't want to you
know you have to you have to celebrate
that it's
what could we possibly say to criticize
that what are you some kind of prude
but we can criticize this bill burr
while um introducing a latino music
category
made a joke god forbid he's a comedian
god forbid the comedian makes a joke
and this is what outraged a lot of
people let's uh let's listen to it
all right hey how many uh feminists are
like going nuts why is this this white
male doing all this latino stuff
uh and the grammy ghost that's it
that was the whole joke a lot of tweets
his name was trending i think it's still
trending on twitter right now people
were upset about that
well i think in fairness it was that and
also he mispronounced
because i guess he gave he gave out a
few awards for in the latino music
category that's what he's making a joke
about there
and uh he mispronounced the name of one
of the artists
with a name that by the way i can't
pronounce either probably neither can
you
so those two things that's offensive
that right there
incredibly offensive not wap in the
strip show and all that
just so we know okay more celebrity news
sarah silverman
uh lashed out on her i think this is on
her podcast she lashed out against
political tribalism and had a lot of
people on the right cheering
cheering what she had to say they kind
of saw it as her maybe defecting from
the left a little bit but let's
let's take a listen and and see what we
think about it here it is
it's the absolutist
ness of the party i am in
that is such a turn off to me
it's so [ __ ] elitist you know for
something called progressive
it allows for zero progress
it's all or nothing no steps toward
all or [ __ ] nothing
again righteousness porn
and i've been thinking about this a lot
just in general
i i just i don't know that i want to be
associated with
any party
i really i think i don't want to be
associated with
any party anymore it just
it comes with too much baggage
every party it comes with so much
[ __ ] baggage that
no ideas can be taken at face value
and without ideas what are we
without a common truth how can we talk
about it
you know republicans might hear an
idea that they would totally agree with
but if it comes from aoc
then they hate it and of course you know
to be honest
when i hear an idea that comes from a
republican
it's suspect to me
we all put we all put too much [ __ ] on
this stuff
we no longer are able to be a nation of
ideas
so that's i agree with much of what she
had to say there
um good points some some level of
insight there which i which i could
appreciate
and she's thinking about you know quote
her own side criticizing her own side
thinking critical about it all that is
is good but once again as the guy
looking for the dark cloud within the
silver lining i have to say
some conservatives anytime you see
something like this from a from a
celebrity like a little bit of criticism
of their own side on on the right we
we tend to way overreact and we think
next thing that we know she's going to
be speaking at cpac
next next year sarah silverman will be
at cpac
and who knows maybe they actually will
invite her that's that's the thing i
wouldn't be surprised if they really did
invite her to come and speak at cpac
which would be a mistake because she's
still not
i can appreciate what she's saying and
agree with with much of it
but she's still not an ally in any
significant way
there's if you're a conservative there's
still a vast
gulf that separates you from sarah
silverman she's not on your side she
never
she probably never will be in in any
meaningful way
because the philosophical differences
are simply
too vast and notice
and we get this a lot from some leftists
who seem like they've
they're kind of leaving the tribe a
little bit because they're criticizing
their own side
but they're not really leaving the tribe
at all because the tribe is defined
philosophically what does your basic
world view they have the same basic
worldview
it's just a disagreement over method
you see the problem with
uh the reactions against leftism's
excesses and its extremes that's what
this is here
problem is that it's only ever a
reaction against leftism's
excesses and extremes
okay but the co as the culture continues
to go left
what was once considered in excess in an
extreme
now becomes normal and so if all you're
ever doing
is is if all you're worried about is
leftism's
you know extreme fringes and you're
saying well we're being too extreme over
here
if that's all you're ever looking at
then eventually you're going to be
defending leftism's extremes because the
culture keeps going left
as the culture goes left excess becomes
normal
leftism's excesses become normal
that's that's the problem so
what what really matters
um what would be really significant is a
philosophical rejection
of leftism a fundamental rejection of
the leftist worldview
now somebody does that and okay now
they're an ally
now we really are on the same side but
if they're maintaining that basic
worldview while saying hey gee guys you
know this we're getting
we're a little aggressive here in the
end that's not really anything i hate to
tell you
that's not much of anything
and not to you know you could kind of i
still think
one of the the most fundamental
questions we could ask a third there are
a couple but like
let's just take one if someone is is
criticizing leftism for being too
extreme and it seems like they're on the
left
side and we're thinking oh maybe they're
defecting
what if we were to ask them um
can men get pregnant in your mind i know
you're worried about leftism being too
extreme but can you
can men get pregnant what do you think
guess is sarah silverman would say yeah
well they can
many of the people on the left who are
worried about left being the left being
too extreme if you would ask them that
question they would say well yeah sure
men can get pregnant
now if they're worried about leftism's
extremism
20 years ago they would be criticizing
exactly that position
now they hold that position while
criticizing the left
being too extreme so you see how the
process works
because they bought into the world view
they are they are adherence to that
philosophy to that religion
totally
uh but yeah it was a great a great point
that she made all the same
number four big news here this is uh all
over the headlines big headline news
here this one is from the ap
it says the vatican decreed monday that
the catholic church cannot bless
same-sex unions since god cannot bless
sin
the vatican's orthodoxy office the
congregation for the doctrine of the
faith issued a formal response monday to
a question
about whether catholic clergy can bless
gay unions
the answer contained in a two-page
explanation published in seven languages
and approved by pope francis
was negative uh the decree distinguished
between the church's welcoming and
blessing of gay people which it upheld
but not their unions since any such
sacramental
recognition could be confused with
marriage the vatican holds that gay
people must be treated with dignity and
respect but that gay sex is
intrinsically
disordered quote unquote catholic
teaching holds that marriage a lifelong
union between a man and woman
is part of god's plan as intended for
the sake of creating new life uh this
is this as i said is treated as i mean
literally the ap called it breaking news
breaking the catholic church does not
endorse same-sex unions
now this is this is not breaking news
this was breaking news i don't know 2000
years ago
and it wasn't even breaking news then
actually
uh it's not breaking news at all this
this has been the consistent teaching of
the church
since its inception for literally for
millennia this has been
the teaching of the church but if you
look at the reaction online of course
people are reacting to this like i can't
believe that the church
this homophobia from the church what are
they talking about
i can't believe they would arrive at
this decision
it's not a decision this has been the
teaching of the church for 2000 years
it's just that the left they really
can't believe
that any institution in the world would
defy them
especially on an issue like this
especially when it comes to sexual
morality
they simply cannot believe they really
did assume that they're disappointed
they simply assumed that the catholic
church would change its official
position on this subject because
they think it should and to them it's so
obvious
that the church is wrong so of course
two thousand years who cares
toss that to the side you know we
do what we want everything should be
changed according to our whims
because that's all that matters who
cares about tradition
throw all tradition to the side all
religion everything throw it to the side
uh just do what we want
that's not only what they what they want
it's also what they expect it's their
actual expectation
and so there's palpable disappointment
that the church has not come out and
reversed its position on marriage
whereas for catholics we we think well
yeah of course
we knew that was going to happen
uh number five crazy story here from fox
it says a pennsylvania woman is facing
misdemeanor charges after allegedly
sending
deep fake naked photos and videos of her
teenage daughters cheerleader rivals
in an effort to get them kicked off the
team or convince them to kill themselves
rafael marie spone of shalfont was
arrested march 5 charged last week with
three counts of cyber harassment of a
child
and three counts of harassment
last summer spona allegedly created
doctored photos and videos of at least
three teenage members of the victory
vipers a competitive cheerleading squad
based in doyle's town
the image appears to show the high
school girls either naked or in bikinis
drinking alcohol and smoking vape pens
um and this was all this is a deep fake
this was all faked
obviously it's not real and now she's
facing misdemeanor charges first of all
how how do you not have
child pornography charges felonies
for something like this and i'm i'm
usually the last guy to advocate that we
make new laws
um you know i think we we make new laws
far too often
but here's one where i think we do need
some new laws i think you need serious
jail time
not just on the child pornography end of
it which of course there should be for
that
but with deep fakes this is going to be
a huge problem
it's already a problem a huge problem as
this technology
becomes more and more convincing
you know and when we get into video
think about how easy it's going to be to
defame someone slander them
and how impossible it will be for them
to prove otherwise
when you can simply manufacture a photo
or a video of them doing some
heinous unspeakable thing
uh there's got to be serious serious
jail time for that
as as a means of dissuading people from
this before it becomes
a major problem in society all right
let's move on to
reading the youtube comments uh jacob
lipsky says
first time watching matt walsh he's much
skinnier than he sounds on audio
not sure i take that i sound like a fat
person i guess
you know i'm going to take that as a
compliment grace
health says the vacant look at biden's
eyes is something that
sadly i recognize it's the look my dad
had a few years ago after he was
diagnosed with alzheimer's
i love my dad so much it would never
have wanted him to go through what biden
has allowed
to happen to him i'm grateful for nancy
reagan who protected her husband's
dignity and lived privately
as ronald reagan succumbed to
alzheimer's disease yeah i
i mentioned the vacant look in joe
biden's eyes when you when you watch him
giving a speech
he he really looks like he doesn't
understand what he's saying
and i don't mean that as a joke i'm
serious
about it and it's not a joke at all it's
not funny that we this is our president
and the guy has no idea what's going on
but if you haven't noticed that the next
time you see him on tv
especially giving prepared remarks which
by the way really the only kind of
remarks that he'll give
because they don't trust him to go off
the cuff but when he's reading the the
prompter
look in his eyes you you can tell he
doesn't understand what he's saying he's
not he's not there
and it is very similar if you've been
around someone who struggled with
alzheimer's dementia
it is a it's a very similar look
because that's what it that's what he
has clearly
um
kayla caleb says hey matt i'm a
conservative but i'm starting to worry
about this dumb q anon thing like
yesterday my mom said that pope francis
eats children on an island
what do i do well maybe he does you know
has pope francis been on an island yes
has he eaten something on an island yes
it's all the evidence you need
right there and then of course for
conspiracy there that is all the
evidence you need
all you need is you need a couple little
things to sort of bookend it and then
you can fill in
the middle part with whatever you want
and that's considered
evidence in your mind um
yeah it is look there there are
plenty of people on the right who go for
this it's not a new phenomenon by the
way
they make a big deal about q anon but
there's conspiracy theorists on both
sides of the aisle
um and it's it's it's there's been a
segment
of conservatives a segment of people on
the right who have always gone for this
kind of thing we just have different
names we use for it
you go all the way back because first
you go further back than this but think
about sandy hook
there's a sign i don't know what the
number was it's significant as a
noticeable portion of people on the
right
who immediately decided based on nothing
that this that this event didn't really
happen it was all a fake or
these were crisis actors and all this
kind of stuff so this kind of this sort
of thing's always been there
it's not a new phenomenon it's a problem
on the right
i think we should try to engage it try
to try to dissuade people from this
could be very difficult to dissuade
people from it
because they're deluded but we should
also remember
that it happens on the left too it's a
bigger problem on the left
because the primary conspiracy theory
there
is the one that has led to the
destruction of our cities two billion
dollars of damage
over the summer the conspiracy theory
that
police officers are out hunting for
black men to murder
that is a conspiracy theory just as
absurd
and lacking in evidence as anything q
anon has come up with
but the effects have been far more
devastating in my mind uh
and then another comment says you're a
prime example of why decent lighting and
some hair gel
can help somebody get way more views
than they deserve well
thank you sir for that compliment of my
lighting i appreciate it as well
i want to take a minute to tell you
about our sponsors paint your life
you know i've been talking about paint
your life for for months now and uh i
told you about the first painting we got
we got a paint your life painting
that we uh that we display proudly in
our living room now it's a painting of
our of our kids and one of our favorite
spots when we go on vacation
um and we love it so much that now we're
getting a second painting as well that's
that tells you everything we
you need to know about how we feel about
paint your life that we're getting the
second one and you can
also get your first paint your life
painting or your second whatever it is
you get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at a
truly affordable price
choose from a team of world-class
artists and work with them until every
detail is perfect
it's a user-friendly platform um and it
lets you order a custom-made
hand-painted portrait in less than five
minutes it's very quick and easy for you
uh all the hard work is gonna be done on
the end with their artists but it's also
very hands-on for you and they're gonna
be asking you all throughout you know
and you're gonna be giving feedback
if you don't like something they can
change it at paintyourlife.com there's
no risk if you don't love the final
painting
your money is refunded guaranteed and
right now is a limited time offer get 20
off your painting that's right 20 off
and free shipping so to get the special
offer text the word matt to sixty four
thousand
that's matt to sixty four thousand text
matt to sixty four thousand paint your
life
celebrate the moments that matter most
terms apply available at
paintyourlife.com
terms again text keyword to matt
and you know we've been talking about it
for a week now but this is where it gets
really exciting because this friday
march 19th it's coming up
this week is the premiere of candace
daily wire's new talk show
hosted by conservative lightning rod
candace owens herself it's no secret
that candace has ruffled some
feathers along her career and i think
there's gonna be a lot of people talking
about what she's got coming up
now you'll get to see her like never
before in her new show candace shows her
personal side to her guests and her live
audience while she tackles the big
political and cultural topics of the
week
with her signature blend of humor and
insight don't forget
candace starts this friday march 19th
and will be exclusive to daily wire
if you aren't a member yet go to
dailywire.com
subscribe and use code candice for 25
off that's dailywire.com
subscribe use code candace for 25 off
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so today we're going to cancel with a
vengeance
grace church school grace church school
achieves the double woke whammy of being
both
in manhattan and episcopal which is just
a long way of saying
that the school is a nest of moral
confusion and insanity
case in point they recently released
their inclusive language guide
and within this 12-page screed the
reader will discover that words like mom
dad and parents
are non-inclusive and therefore
offensive and therefore should not be
used
now we'll dive deeper into the guide in
a moment but first here's a local news
report about the controversy surrounding
the guide
including the reaction from the
expectedly pathetic specimen who runs
the school
we'll hear what he has to say as well
let's listen
grace church school an independent
school in greenwich village prides
itself in welcoming students of all
faiths or no faith at all
but now it's finding itself facing
criticism for encouraging words that
promote
an inclusive environment like saying
people instead of boys and girls
and grown-up instead of parent since not
all children are being raised by a
mother
and or father one person tweeted grace
church school in new york should be
ashamed of themselves saying
that you can't use the words mom and dad
and you're supposed to use
folks or family george davidson is head
of grace church school
we're not telling people not to call
their parents mom and dad that's the
silliest thing anybody ever came here
and it's not even a word police it is
rather a guide to inclusive language if
you want to use it
back in september the school posted this
inclusive language guide at the request
of teachers and parents
who wanted help in making sure their
interactions were affirming and uniting
parents we spoke with say they're
supportive of the guidelines and proud
the school is also describing best
practices for discussing
faith learning differences and physical
disabilities
like choosing the words physically
disabled instead of handicapped
we can't lump people together and assume
anything about people
and that's at the core of what this is
about natalie egan is the founder of
translator which builds diversity equity
and inclusion analytic software
for schools she applauds grace church's
pioneering spirit
as we look to the future you know it's
really important that we start to
you know shape our our future leaders to
to be inclusive of all people
you know regardless of of anything
whoever they are
it is what we're proud of whoever they
are
it's what we're proud of well i might
critique that statement if i had the
slightest idea what it meant
whoever they are it's what we're proud
of but this is what wokeness actually is
most of the time total nonsense
literally i mean nonsense in the
definitions
definitional sense of the word as in
things that make no sense
wokeness is in practice a jumble of
semi-coherent buzzwords mixed together
in entirely incoherent ways
that's because the core idea the only
idea
really is that feelings come before all
else the only thing that matters
the only thing period is how the
individual feels
well certain individuals anyway a very
select group of individuals as it turns
out wokeness
is not only incoherent but elitist and
oppressive it puts
the feelings and psychological comfort
of a tiny minority of the population
above the emotional and practical
concerns
of everyone else on earth how many
people on the globe as a percentage
would actually find references to mom
and dad or even parents
as offensive how many would profess
themselves otherized by such words
what percent of people would have a
problem with it point one percent
point zero one percent point zero zero
one percent
whatever the percentage is and whoever
those people are and however numerous
they are or aren't
they are all that matter that's the
message it's only them they're the only
ones that matter
so let's take a look at this guide it
says right at the top the goal of this
guide is to provide the the community
with more inclusive language that is
aligned with the mission of grace church
school
while we recognize hateful language that
promotes racism misogyny homophobia and
other forms of discrimination
are already addressed in our school
handbooks we also recognize that we can
do more than ban hateful language we can
use language to create welcoming and
inclusive spaces
this guide addresses ways we can remove
harmful assumptions
from the way we interact with each other
then there's a chart
and on one side it says instead of and
lists all the phrases that you shouldn't
use
and on the other it says at grace we say
and it lists the alternatives
remember how george davidson the head of
the school assured us that they aren't
banning words like mom and dad don't be
silly
why that's the most ridiculous thing
he's ever heard they're only suggesting
different words that you can use if you
want to
except that in the guide words like mom
and dad are framed as quote
hateful language that promotes racism
misogyny homophobia and other forms of
discrimination
and the alternatives are not offered as
suggestions but as things
we say at grace church school not things
we'd like you to say but things you will
say so as always with the woke brigade
they enact their insane agenda and then
deny it
and get away with denying it because the
agenda is so insane that normal people
can't believe anyone would actually want
to do this
now looking at the chart here's uh some
of the of the
banned words and their replacements
we'll go through some of these
so it says instead of boys and girls
guys ladies and gentlemen
at grace we say people folks friends
readers mathematicians that last one's
kind of specific
uh instead of when reading a book rather
than boy girl on this page
say child person character
instead of using pet names like
sweetheart honey or similar
say the child's name or child slash
friend in the blue shirt
yes that's that's a that's a great way
to build rather than than saying
sweetheart or honey just say hey kid in
the blue shirt
get over here um
and then let's see so that's a lot of
gender stuff and then with families it
says instead of saying mom and dad say
grown-ups
folks or family instead of parents
say grown-ups folks family or guardians
um instead of nanny or babysitter say
say
caregiver or guardian
why is that better than nanny who knows
but just just because nanny is a word
that people have used in the past
and that makes it offensive let's come
up with a different word that means
exactly the same thing and there's no
reason why
one is better than the other um
instead of husband wife boyfriend or
girlfriend say spouse
partner significant other
and then and then it gives you so those
are those are the language guides
and that goes into ra race and ethnicity
instead of saying diverse or minority
say person of color
instead of asking where are you from ask
what is your cultural
ethnic background and instead of saying
what race are you
ask how they self-identify well that's
important because
you know it's they might identify as a
race that they aren't
so you got to make sure that we account
for that now a lot can be said about
these kinds of orwellian speech rules
but
one thing that really jumps out is just
how boring and sterile and flavorless
they seek to make
human communication remove all the
personality from it
all the character right instead
this is why we take sweetheart take away
sweetheart and honey and you know the
kind of pet names especially that women
will
use for for kids kid in the blue shirt
child in the blue shirt organism in the
blue shirt
please come here presently take all the
specific
specificity out as well you know your
mom and dad are folks
your wife is partner this is not only an
oddly distanced and neutral way to refer
to your own loved ones
but it also really doesn't tell the
listener anything about them
i mean a partner can be anyone you could
have a partner during a science lab in
10th grade
folks is a word that can be applied to
your parents or to a random group of
strangers
yes the real words the better words wife
and mom and dad are
exclusive but that's the point in order
for me to know what you're saying
you have to speak in such a way as to
exclude all of the things
you're not saying i have to know what
you're not saying in order to know what
you
are saying so the leftist rules are not
only
not only lead to bland language but the
language that hardly succeeds in
being language at all because it hardly
conveys meaning
and that's what language is supposed to
do now one other point to make here
i said that these kinds of speech codes
are meant to cater to a small minority
and they are
but the idea is to make it so that
eventually
the small minority is not a minority
the language changes don't reflect
changes and cultural sensibilities or
tastes
they're meant to affect those changes
cause them
they don't reflect the changes they're
supposed to effect the changes
the school isn't so much saying that mom
and dad are
seen as offensive words to lots of
people but that mom and dad
should be seen as offensive to lots of
people
see the rules from the left are
prescriptive not descriptive
it is prescription disguised as
description
the people changing the language want to
change the way
you see the world they want to change
your values your beliefs
and changing language can be an
effective way of achieving that
see we make the mistake we make a
mistake when we boil all this stuff down
to the left just being overly sensitive
snowflakes and all that
sensitivity really has nothing to do
with it the truth is a lot more sinister
than that this is brainwashing
this is just another form of
indoctrination
and for that grace church school is
certainly without a doubt absolutely
canceled
and we will leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day
[Music]
godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel ledoski the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. if you
prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there